Typhoid, pretty sure that's when you get
like a knuckle in your knee.
(up-beat music)
(marker squeaks)
I have not taken the SAT before.
I took the ACT.
I've done prep for both
the SAT and the ACT.
I have never taken the
SAT, but in high school
my junior year I did take the ACT.
I took the SAT once, got
a eleven hundred on it.
- [Interviewer] Do you know
when the first SAT was given?
1945?
(buzz)
I don't know.
400 B.C.
(buzz)
- [Interviewer] It was 1926.
There's going to be questions
about like shoveling
and like raising cattle or something.
A dealer bought a lot of three horses
and some mules for $600,
he sold the lot for 820.
If he gained $40 on each
horse, and $50 for each mule,
how many mules were there?
I feel like this would
be the type of question
that people would make fun of.
They'd just post memes about it.
I could maybe see this in
a third grade math problem.
To be quite honest, I don't
know like what a reasonable
price for three horses and some mules are.
Two mules is my final answer.
(bell dings)
Two of those were mules.
I thought this was tricky.
Premise, there are 12 months in a year,
but Washington and Lincoln were born
in the same month, February.
Conclusion, the two greatest
Americans of the next
200 years will be born in February.
Sure, Washington and
Lincoln, you know people knew
their birthdays, but today,
I didn't even know they
were born in February.
There's a lot of great people in history.
I know like Martin Luther
King Junior, Obama,
Gandhi, oh but he's not American.
Probably false.
(bell dings)
Cause when I think of February today,
I think of Martin Luther King.
The statement that the moon
is made of green cheese is
absurd, misleading,
improbable, unfair, or wicked.
Does green cheese even exist?
You can chose like blue
cheese, that's a real cheese.
First of all, why would
this be on the SAT?
What knowledge is this
gonna, like, enhance.
Improbable.
(bell dings)
It's a weird word choice,
maybe it was used a lot back in the day.
Like, oh Hans, that's a wicked
cow you got on the field.
(buzz)
Improbable and absurd, I feel
like they go hand in hand.
But because you're in high school,
I hope that you know the moon
is not made of green cheese.
If a package containing 20
cigarettes costs 15 cents,
how many cigarettes can
be bought for 90 cents?
This has to be back in 1920 something,
cause cigarettes are definitely
costing way more 15 cents.
This question would definitely not make it
onto the real SATs.
So 120 cigarettes is my answer.
(bell dings)
You would have to buy four cigarettes
with 16 cigarettes left.
(buzz)
- [Interviewer] That is incorrect.
Really? Oh, okay.
If a man's salary is $20 a
week and he spends $14 a week,
how long will it take him to save $300?
I mean I guess it depends how old he is.
Because if I was making $20,
no wait no, I don't want
to be making $20 a week.
What can you buy for $6?
A pack of gum?
That's not even a man, it has to be a kid.
Probably doing chores.
My final answer is 42
weeks and a couple days.
(buzz)
Fifty weeks.
(bell dings)
Don't SAT questions have
multiple choice anyway?
I would have got 50 right.
Two of the below four words are opposites
or nearly opposites, pick those two.
Opposites.
Ecc-less-ee-uh-tal
Intricate, obvious, and tepid.
Cool.
It's all about, you know,
taking out the words
you don't know, that's
what they wanted you to do.
Uh-clec-li-as-cal, I think
that is a form of grain
they used to farm in
the fields back in 1926.
(buzz)
Intricate and obvious.
(bell dings)
I'm gonna do ecclesiastical and obvious.
(buzz)
And no I didn't just get that
answer cause I don't know
what ecclesiastical means or tepid means.
(up-beat music)
Yeah I wonder if they did
have classes back in the day,
they're like okay, here's
your next cigarette problem.
SAT and all of the
people who come together
to make it, realize that
time is changing really fast.
Honestly, thank goodness I did
not have to take this test.
I promise I did better on the real test.
If they would have
worded them differently,
I probably would have
got the better answers.
What was my score equivalent to?
Like what college would I have gotten
into with that percentage?
(up-beat music)
(mechanical whooshes and creaks)